hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and regular
listeners will know that we've been
doing a lot of quantum mechanics
discussions here at mindscape we talked
at great length with David Albert about
his skepticism about the many-worlds
interpretation I had a flipped podcast
with Rob Reed where he asked me
questions about the many-worlds
interpretation we did a little bit on
the history of quantum mechanics in the
20th century with Adam Becker and of
course he mentioned quantum mechanics
when we talked to people like Leonard
Susskind or Roger Penrose all of this
has a purpose as you might know I have a
book coming out in fact I'm releasing
this podcast the day before the new book
is due to be published it'll be called
something deeply hidden quantum worlds
and the emergence of space-time arriving
wherever books arrive on September 10th
2019 and so I've been sort of getting
people excited about quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics is an intrinsically
awesome thing to talk about but there is
a hidden agenda here that I'm not
keeping very hidden
so today's podcast today's episode is
the capstone of that effort it's going
to be a solo podcast just me talking and
I'm going to focus on this issue of how
space-time emerges from quantum
mechanics so I've talked a lot about
many worlds already and that's most of
the focus of the book but in the book I
want to use many worlds I don't want to
just say here it is I want to make the
case that it really helps us as
physicists to take seriously the
foundations of quantum mechanics and how
we make progress on difficult issues
like reconciling gravity with quantum
mechanics really can depend on what our
favorite formulation is in particular I
want to argue that if you believe or at
least put a high credence in the
many-worlds version of quantum mechanics
you can come up with the philosophy that
we shouldn't be quantizing gravity at
all what we should be doing is finding
gravity within quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics is a more fundamental theory
than general relativity than Einstein's
theory of curved space-time so a quantum
mechanics first perspective might help
us solve this knotty problem now this is
very very much recent research
cutting-edge stuff and it's research
that I've been involved in so I have a
personal perspective I'm not completely
unbiased and also of course there are
many questions that are unanswered
everything that I say might not be
completely wrong but be completely
useless in figuring out ultimately how
to reconcile gravity with quantum
mechanics but we don't know yet that's
why we have to try it that's what
theoretical physics is all about I'm
very hopeful that we'll get lessons for
how the universe works regardless of
whether this particular approach to
quantum gravity and Immersion space-time
turns out to be the right one I should
also say there are no prerequisites here
okay if you haven't been following our
other discussions of quantum mechanics
or anybody's discussions of quantum
mechanics I will still try to make it so
that everyone can understand what's
going on in this episode of mindscape it
is pretty mind bendy stuff you know in
some sense many worlds generally in this
particular immersion space-time
perspective are really as quantum as you
can get in the sense that they do not
hang on to any relics from our classical
intuitive version of the world as a
starting point we start purely quantum
mechanical and we try to derive emerge
all the classical real world stuff
around us that requires an ability not
to be an expert in physics or anything
like that but to put yourself in the
position of imagining that the world is
fundamentally different than you think
it is of course like I said that might
not actually be true but that's the
attitude the philosophy that we're
pursuing today so that's why I think
that it's still useful to do even if our
particular ideas don't turn out to be
the right ones it's very helpful very
good exercise to get your brain into a
point where you can imagine a world that
just seems utterly different than the
world we're familiar with and to be able
to see how the familiar world can emerge
out of that but wait at the last minute
we decided to be fun to add an excerpt
from the audiobook recording of
something deeply hidden to the end of
this podcast so if you hang on to the
very end you'll get a short snippet of
me
from Chapter seven on the origin of
probability and structure in the many
worlds theory and with that let's go
[Music]
I promise that you wouldn't need to know
anything about quantum mechanics to
follow this podcast but I'm gonna be
talking about quantum mechanics quite a
bit so I suppose I should start by
telling you what quantum mechanics is
now sadly we immediately hit a problem
when we're trying to explain what
quantum mechanics is it's the problem of
what is often called interpretations of
quantum mechanics but that's a very bad
label it's more like formulations of
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics is
the most spectacularly successful theory
that physicists have ever devised and
yet we don't understand what it actually
says we have a recipe we have a cookbook
for using quantum mechanics in certain
particular situations but if you ask ok
but what is really going on physicists
do not agree and we have multiple very
very different formulations of quantum
theory quantum theory and quantum
mechanics and quantum physics all mean
the same thing we have multiple
different formulations which all lead to
the recipe they match in other words our
experimental predictions for what
quantum mechanics says but they're
fundamentally different when they answer
questions about what's really going on
so since I'm not going to be comparing
and contrasting all the different
formulations of quantum mechanics here
in this episode I'm just going to be
talking in the context of my favorite
interpretation which is the many-worlds
interpretation
now many-worlds was formulated by Hugh
Everett back in the 1950s it has a bad
reputation in some places because you
say well there are all these worlds
right the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics literally does say
that whenever you observe a quantum
mechanical system the wave function of
the universe which is the way that
quantum mechanics describes all of
reality branches it splits into multiple
copies and there are now multiple copies
of you one in each different universe
and those universes don't interact
anymore they go on their separate ways
okay so that's a little mind-bending all
by itself it's not going to be a real
focus here today the point I want to
make is that this idea of many universes
many worlds of quantum mechanics that's
the label given to the theory but it's
not the central point of the theory
Everett nor anyone else didn't start by
saying well maybe there are many worlds
maybe that makes everything make a lot
more sense rather he took the
fundamental ingredients of quantum
mechanics and stripped them down to
their bare essences so let me explain
what those fundamental ingredients are
and then you will see how many worlds
pops out of that this is gonna be very
very quick but I think it'll be enough
to understand what's going on when we
talk about explaining quantum mechanics
we always go down to elementary
particles right pick an electron one of
those little particles that orbits the
nucleus to make an atom and the reason
we do that is because that's where
quantum mechanical effects are most
obvious the whole world is quantum
mechanical you and I okay the rules of
quantum mechanics but we don't notice
classical mechanics the rules set up by
Isaac Newton you know F equals MA
there's positions and velocities and on
the basis of the forces acting on a
system you can predict what's going to
happen next
Newtonian mechanics is a really good
approximation to the world we see it
only fails to be a good approximation
when we look at microscopic systems like
individual elementary particles and the
point is that in classical mechanics in
Newtonian mechanics if you had a
particle what is that that's an object
that is point like right it just has a
certain location in space and Isaac
Newton would say it also has a velocity
through space and if you tell me the
position and the velocity of a particle
you're telling me the state you're
telling me all the information I need to
know to predict what will happen next if
you know the other forces acting on the
particle caused by other particles out
there or fields or whatever you can
predict the entire future of the
universe this is called the clockwork
universe Laplace's daemon if you've ever
heard of that concept Laplace
pierre-simon Laplace the French
mathematician and physicist said that if
there were a demon that knew everything
about the current state of the universe
he could predict the future and retro
dick the past with perfect accuracy he
didn't actually say demon he said vast
intelligence but you know what we mean
so
that's the Newtonian classical universe
how is quantum mechanics different you
might think that quantum mechanics adds
a certain fuzziness to the classical
picture right quantum mechanics says
that when we predict the outcome of an
observation we don't know exactly what
we're going to see everyone agrees on
that
that is definitely part of the quantum
mechanical story so unlike classical
mechanics if I knew exactly the position
and momentum of a particle I could
predict what's going to happen next and
I could tell you what measurement
outcome I would get in quantum mechanics
I cannot even in principle make
absolutely reliable predictions for any
observation I want to make so if you
started your brain with a classical
intuitive perspective there are
particles they're moving in some way you
might think about quantum mechanics as
just adding some uncertainty some
fuzziness to that and that's a lot
that's a big part of the popular picture
of what quantum mechanics really says
but it's actually deeper than that
and the many-worlds perspective this is
where it comes in in quantum mechanics
the position and velocity of a particle
it's not just that you don't know what
they are or you can't predict what you
will measure them to be it's that they
don't exist positions and velocities are
not what quantify the state of a
particle in quantum mechanics
what does quantify the state of a
particle something called the wave
function and we think about the wave
function as kind of a cloud of
probability that is concentrated in
certain regions and the wave function is
the answer to the question when I
observe a particle what's the
probability going to be that I see it
doing different things in fact
technically there's something called the
born rule in quantum mechanics which
says the probability of a measurement
outcome is the wave function squared so
intuitively we might think that the wave
function is somehow capturing our
ignorant we're not exactly sure where
the particle is or how fast it's moving
but if you're hardcore about it if
you're our many worlds or you say it's
not about ignorant it's not about us not
knowing something about the particle the
wave function is the entire state of the
particle again other
relations of quantum mechanics will
disagree about that but many worlds is
pure it's lean and mean and austere it
says there's a wavefunction and there is
nothing else
so the fundamental feature of this
version of quantum mechanics is that
what you see when you measure a quantum
system is very very different from what
really exists when you're not measuring
it what you see is indeed a particle
with a location with a velocity those
are the possible measurement outcomes
but what's really there is this spread
out wavefunction this cloud of
probability and the rules of quantum
mechanics tell you how to relate what's
really there the wave function the
spread out thing to the possible
observational outcomes
now as human beings we struggle with
this right we don't want there to be a
distinction between what we see and what
really exists we privilege what we see
right what we see seems real and
tangible to us and that's why some of
these alternatives to many worlds have
been proposed they try to make the
connection between what we see and what
is real much more vivid and direct so
even though many worlds is extremely
austere and pure and simple it's a big
distance between the formalism of many
worlds and the reality many worlds is
just the statement that there are
quantum wave functions that's what
reality is it's a quantum wave function
and those wave functions evolve
according to an equation which we call
the Schrodinger equation named after
Aaron Schrodinger so it's exactly like
Newtonian mechanics there's a state in
Newtonian mechanics the state is the
position in the velocity and quantum
mechanics the state is the wavefunction
and there's an equation in Newtonian
mechanics there's newton's laws which
tell you how particles move in quantum
mechanics there's the Schrodinger
equation the difference is that if you
take the Schrodinger equation seriously
you find as you Everett pointed out that
the world branches it splits into
multiple copies that did not happen in
Newtonian mechanics it necessarily
happens according to the Schrodinger
equation of quantum mechanics now you
might think well if that were true why
isn't every version of quantum mechanics
on many worlds
and the answer is that other versions of
quantum mechanics work hard to get rid
of the other worlds the other worlds the
multiple copies of the reality around us
are clearly predicted by the existence
of wave functions in the Schrodinger
equation that was not put in by Everett
it pops out of the formalism other
formulations of quantum mechanics say no
we don't like that that's not what the
world seems like to us so we will get
rid of the other worlds one way or
another
Everett's move is as much therapeutic as
it is physical he says look it's okay
that there are other worlds we live in
one of them at any one time and we
should deal with that and therefore the
fundamental underlying formalism of
everybody in quantum mechanics is way
simpler than any other possible theory
but it raises a challenge right if the
fundamental nature of reality is some
abstract quantum wave function it's not
you know stuff with positions and
velocities then how do you go from that
abstract quantum wave function to the
world we see after all for hundreds of
years classical mechanics served
perfectly well to describe the world you
know you don't need quantum mechanics to
fly a rocket to the moon the moon is
there you can see its position its
velocity and you can get there so
there's this huge question that becomes
important if you become an ever Eddy in
which is why does the world look
classical at all why was ordinary
Newtonian mechanics ever thought to be a
pretty good approximation to what the
world does so there's a slight shift of
emphasis here that professional
physicists will perhaps appreciate but
the person on the street might not
exactly because we're so used to the
classical world even after we've been
taught quantum mechanics even after
we've taught our students what it means
to do quantum mechanics and do the
calculations and so forth
we still can't help but being classical
deep in our bones when we construct a
quantum mechanical theory whether it's a
theory of a single particle or the
standard model of particle physics or
whatever you want to think about we
typically start with a classical theory
and then we quantize it there is a
procedure there are different procedures
actually that are sort of complementary
to each other but there are ways of
starting with a classical description
and constructing the analogous quantum
mechanical theory of it that's called
the process of quantization now we can
do that right we can do that it might be
hard it was hard for quantum
electrodynamics that's why it took a lot
of time and people like firemen and
Schwinger won the Nobel Prize
tominaga it there can be subtle issues
that arise when you start with the
classical theory and start to quantize
it but if you are good ever ready and
you think that even that very first move
is probably kind of wrongheaded because
the world isn't classical classical
mechanics is not there the foundation of
reality the world is fundamentally
quantum what we should be doing is not
starting with some classical description
of the world and quantizing it what we
should be doing is starting with a
quantum description of the world and
extracting some classical approximation
that's where the word emergence comes in
and when we talk about the emergence of
space-time it's not emergence like a
little baby bird
emerges from its egg it's not something
developing over time it's the fact that
we have a fundamental description in
this case a wave function of the
universe and there's an approximate
description that describes what happens
under certain circumstances and we call
that the higher-level emergent
description okay so even though the
fundamental rules of ever-ready in
quantum mechanics are very simple the
task that it faces us with is very hard
you're given something very abstract and
hard to conceptualize a wavefunction of
nothing at all right just the abstract
idea of a wavefunction and then you're
supposed to figure out afterward what
that is a wave function of in other
words what is the best way that we can
talk in some what classical vocabulary
about this quantum mechanical theory
that we have okay so when we look around
us we see a world like I said that looks
pretty classical there are people there
are tables and chairs there are planets
and stars and so
not only do we look and measure that
these things have positions and they
have velocities but those position
positions and velocities more or less
obey Newton's laws they obey more or
less the classical description that
Newton came up with why is that true I
will pause to parenthetically mention
here that when as professional
physicists when we teach quantum
mechanics to our students or
undergraduates who you know typically
take quantum mechanics in their second
or third year as physics undergraduates
we completely lie to them we do a very
very bad job of explaining how the
classical world emerges from the
underlying quantum description and part
of that is that even we physics
professors still think classically the
emergence of a classical description is
sort of natural to us so we don't try
very hard to justify it right it's not a
surprise the classical mechanics work we
see it working all around us all the
time
so consider a single electron okay
that's what we do when we do quantum
mechanics we take single particles as I
said there's a wave function for that
electron in principle it could be spread
out anywhere but you can say let's start
the wave function the electrons was
localized
somewhere there's a place in the
universe where the electron more or less
is if you want to say it this way you
could say were I to observe it with very
very high probability I would find it
localized in this particular place and
you can ask if the electron is not bound
inside an atom or anything like that
what is the prediction for how the
electron should behave if it were a
classical particle you would say tell me
its position tell me its velocity I will
trace out its trajectory through space
like throwing a baseball seeing it fly
through the air the Schrodinger equation
is the analogous quantum mechanical
equation that says how the wave function
of the electron will change and the
answer is it spreads out everywhere it
does not travel on some well-defined
classical looking trajectory this was of
great disappointment to urban vertigo
himself he was hopeful that his equation
would predict that wave functions would
be kind of
article like in their behavior the truth
is the opposite wavefunctions want to
spread out all over the place so for a
single electron there's kind of no such
thing as a classical limit single
electrons by themselves do not act
classically at all
well we teach our students is okay
that's fine but if you get together a
large number of particles right if you
get a macroscopic system like a grain of
dust out there in interstellar space
that has many many atoms in it then once
you get that large number of particles
things begin to act classically that is
a complete lie at least as we say it I
mean it's true that things do at
classically but not just because there's
a large number of particles in there
when you have that dust grain out in the
middle of interstellar space
you could easily analyze that dust grain
by thinking of its center of mass right
basically the position of the dust grain
and its center of mass velocity and then
all the jiggles of the individual
electrons and nuclei within the dust
grain and you can ask from the
Schrodinger equation what should the
center of mass of the dust grain do and
the answer is it should spread out all
over the place it's not that it should
follow some classical trajectory at all
so why in the world if all that's true
and we lie to our students why in the
world do things look approximately
classical why does the moon follow its
classical Newtonian trajectory orbiting
around the earth the answer is that the
moon or the dust grain or the electron
is not out there all by itself that
there are many many things in the
universe and this is a crucial feature
of quantum mechanics that is
fundamentally different from the
classical picture of the world in the
classical picture of the world there can
be many things out there in the universe
that can be many atoms and electrons and
photons and so forth but you can treat
them all one by one you can treat them
all individually you can say well this
atom is doing this this particle is
doing that other thing sometimes they
will interact with each other and bump
into each other and that's fine but the
state the intrinsic nature of each
particle is a separate thing in quantum
mechanics that is no longer
true you might guess well here's an
electron it has a wave function here's a
proton it has its wave function there's
another electron with its wave function
no that is not how quantum mechanics
works there are not separate wave
functions for every particle in the
universe there is only one wave function
if we want to be grandiose we can call
the wave function the wave function of
the universe but the wave function no
matter what kind of system you're
looking at is of the entire system all
at once okay so if you think of the wave
function in this sort of classical pre
quantum mechanical way of asking
questions if you said well what the wave
function does is it tells me the
probability of observing different
measurement outcomes then the wave
function of the universe says if I were
to observe everything in the universe
all at once what is the probability I
would get different measurement outcomes
okay
and if you just simplify your life by
saying okay let's forget the whole
universe let's just take two particles
right so you can have one particle that
has a wave function that you might think
has a wave function it could be a little
bit of a probability to see it over
there a little bit of a probability to
see it over here and there's another
particle likewise it has different
probabilities but the combined system
can be entangled the world the word
entanglement is crucially important in
quantum mechanics and what it can say is
you if you were to observe the positions
of these two particles
you might not know ahead of time what
you're going to observe there might be a
probability right of seeing this over
here or over there but the wavefunction
of the whole system can have the
property that if you observe one
particle in a certain position then you
know exactly where the other particle is
going to be if you observe the first
particle in a different position the
second particle would also be in a
different position they're entangled
with each other you can't predict
exactly where either one will be
observed but you know when you observe
one where the other one will be this is
a feature of the fact that they don't
have separate quantum states
there's just the quantum state though
wavefunction for the entire universe
okay this seems like maybe a bit of a
technicality like sure it's true like
everyone who knows
quantum mechanics appreciates that what
I just said is true and yet we don't
really emphasize it when we teach
quantum mechanics to our students you
know you can take an entire one semester
introductory course in quantum mechanics
and never really hear about entanglement
and I think that that is a crime
personally I think this is a disaster I
think that we do our undergraduate
students an incredible disservice by
de-emphasizing the role of entanglement
in quantum mechanics and this is why one
of my many ambitions for the next few
years is to write a new textbook for
quantum mechanics for undergraduates
because I think that entanglement should
be absolutely front and center
entanglement more than anything else is
what makes the quantum world different
from the classical world so let's get
back to our little dust grain right our
little dust grain floating through empty
space why does it seem to follow a more
or less classical trajectory an
important we can't go through all the
details sorry about that you know
there's there's equations involved I'm
not gonna be able to do everything what
I want to emphasize right here is that
an important part of the answer to that
question comes from the fact that the
state of the dust grain becomes
entangled with the rest of the world in
particular there are photons right
filling empty space such as the Cosmic
Microwave Background photons let over
from the Big Bang these photons keep
bumping into the dust grain and when
they bump into the dust grain the state
of the photon becomes entangled with the
state of the grain okay so we are not
keeping track of the state of all those
photons we do not know the position or
the wavefunction of every single photon
in the Cosmic Microwave Background we're
ignoring the effects of the photons they
don't change the momentum of the dust
grain a lot the dust grain is a big
massive thing and the photon is a little
tiny ignoring but the fust grain rather
is constantly being monitored it's
constantly interacting with the set of
all of these photons all everywhere in
the universe that are bumping into it
and that constant monitoring branches
the wave function of the universe and on
every one branch it will look to a very
good approximation like the dust
Rane is following a classical trajectory
this monitoring this fact that the
macroscopic system the dust grain
becomes entangled with its environment
as we call it all the other photons or
all the other things you don't keep
track of in the universe that's called
decoherence the reason why the world
often looks approximately classical is
because what should be a wave function
spread out all over the place is
monitored by the environment and D
coheres and different parts of the wave
function go their own separate way so
rather than treating the dust grain as
something that is in some sense spread
out everywhere on every branch of the
wave function on every individual part
of reality it looks to us like the dust
grain is following a single classical
trajectory and that's true for you or me
or the moon or the Stars or any big
thing in the universe any big
macroscopic system in the universe we
are constantly being monitored by the
rest of the universe by the environment
and in every one part of the wave
function every world things look
approximately classical and it's all
ultimately because of entanglement with
something deeply hidden being published
this week this is a great time to talk
about audible audible is your wonderful
source for audio books books you can
listen to at any time the great thing
about audible is you can listen to the
books on your mobile device
you can listen to them on your desktop
you can listen to them by a Bluetooth
and a million different ways while
you're walking around while you're doing
exercise while you're in your car
commuting while you're doing other
chores you can be hearing fiction books
non-fiction books whatever you like
every month as a member of audible you
can get one audio book regardless of
price and you get two audible originals
from a fresh selection now you know that
my own book is coming out I read it in
the audiobook format but there's also
audible books for Leonard Susskind for
Roger Penrose for Adam Becker and so
forth we have a wonderful offer for
mindscape listeners you can start
listening with a 30 day audible trial
and you can choose one audiobook and two
audible originals absolutely free visit
audible.com slash mindscape
or text mindscape - 500 - 500 that's 500
- 500 start listening now okay rant over
that was just me trying to get it off my
chest complaining about how badly we do
when we teach people quantum mechanics
as undergraduates let's get back to the
task at hand which is trying to
understand how the natural world the
world that we observe with our eyeballs
emerges out of this abstract quantum
wave function clearly decoherence and
entanglement are going to play a huge
role but there's many different ways
that different quantum mechanical
systems can become entangled with each
other right
again let's let's be a little bit more
specific and homed in on why we see this
particular kind of world and the answer
I'm going to give you a the answer and
then we'll justify it is basically
because of the feature called locality
locality in this sense says when two
parts of the universe let's say two
photons or two electrons or two
particles of any sort when they interact
with each other they interact with each
other when they bump into each other or
at least when they're very very nearby
in space okay that might be let me just
step back a little bit you might think
well look the Sun is far away and yet
the earth feels its gravitational pull
so we're not right next to each other
what is this feature that you're calling
locality and that's true but there's a
gravitational field that stretches from
the Sun to the earth the Sun does not
interact directly with the earth the Sun
interacts with the gravitational field
at the position of the Sun and that
interacts with the gravitational field
just a little bit further away from the
Sun which interacts with a gravitational
field just a little bit further away
than that all the way up to the earth
the field theory that we use the theory
of the gravitational field is of course
Einstein's general theory of relativity
that's the best theory of gravity we
have right now
Einstein says that space and time kind
of have a life of their own they have a
geometry and that geometry changes over
time in the famous words of John Wheeler
matter tells space-time how to curve
and space-time tells matter how to move
so there's a give-and-take between
matter and energy in the universe and
the gravitational field around it as
specified by the curvature of space-time
so even the gravitational force obeys
this idea of locality you interact with
something when you are at the same
position as that other thing is and you
might think well how else could it be
right and you know what where else would
it be when you interacted with something
but think about that Newtonian version
of the world right think about classical
mechanics I told you that the state of a
particle is its position and also its
velocity okay but two particles interact
when their positions are the same or
nearly the same they don't interact when
their velocities are the same or when
their velocities are opposite you know
so they add up to zero or anything like
that velocities have nothing to do with
it there's something special about the
idea position position is the thing that
determines the fact that interactions
happen when things are nearby to each
other in other words position determines
whether two things are going to interact
with each other directly or not a good
example of this in the quantum
mechanical context is the famous
Schrodinger's cat oK you've all heard of
Schrodinger's cat Schroedinger says you
put a cat in a box you hook up a
complicated quantum mechanical
experiment so there's a probability that
poison gas will be released and kill the
cat and there's absolutely no reason why
it needs to be poison gas in my
discussions of Schrodinger's cat I like
to make it sleeping gas so we can just
put the cat to sleep there's no reason
to kill the cat okay we don't need be
violent in our physics of thought
experiments but the point is everyone
agrees who does quantum mechanics that
if you have some radioactive source
let's say that is going to either admit
a particle or not that's a probabilistic
statement but really what the quantum
mechanical description says is that
there is a wavefunction and part of the
wavefunction says this nucleus of an
atom has emitted a particle it's
radioactive or it hasn't emitted a
particle yet okay and
the thing about quantum mechanics is
thing about wavefunctions is that you
can exist in a superposition that's why
a wavefunction is not just a way of
characterizing our ignorant it's not
that you don't know whether the nucleus
has emitted a particle or not if the
quantum mechanics says the state of the
nucleus the state of the wave function
of the universe is that part of it
describes a nucleus that has emitted a
particle and part of it has described a
nucleus that is not emitted a particle
and both parts are real and in other
versions of quantum mechanics part of
the wave function goes away magically
somehow in Eveready in quantum mechanics
they both remain real there becomes a
world in which the nucleus has emitted
the particle in a world in which it is
not so into the Schrodinger's cat
thought experiment which Schrodinger was
trying to do was to bring into question
whether or not quantum mechanics made
sense okay you might think look further
is one of the founders of quantum
mechanics of course he thinks quantum
mechanics make sense but Schrodinger
like Einstein always wondered whether or
not quantum mechanics was really the
final story it seemed to lead to some
kind of weird counterintuitive results
so what Schrodinger does in his thought
experiment is figure out a way to get
that wave function of the nucleus that
is going to either radioactively decay
or not and amplify the uncertainty in it
amplify the superposition to include a
macroscopic system like a cat so if
you're on the branch of the wavefunction
where the nucleus decayed then the
hammerfell the gas is dispersed through
the box and the cat falls asleep because
it's sleeping gas now and in the other
branch of the wavefunction none of that
happens and the cat is still awake so
Schrodinger says in the box before I
open it up and look there's a
superposition of the cat the cat is
neither asleep nor awake it's in a
superposition of both possibilities and
then again Schrodinger says according to
the conventional rules of quantum
mechanics when I open the box I observe
what's inside and crucially I never
observe a cat in a superposition of
being awake
or asleep I either observe the cat awake
or I observe it asleep the traditional
formulation of quantum mechanics says
that's because the wavefunction
collapses when you observe it yes
it says the wavefunction was in a
superposition of a wake cat and a sleep
cat before you open the box but when you
open the box you looked at it you
performed an observation and the
wavefunction changed suddenly and
unpredictably this is in complete
contradiction to what the Schrodinger
equation would say happens okay this
idea of the collapse of the wavefunction
upon making an observation is at the
heart of what's called the Copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
it is what has bothered physicists and
physics students for generations now
after all what do you mean make an
observation of what's inside the box
does it have to be a human being making
the observation what if another cat
observed it does a cat in the Box
observe itself does that count what
about a video camera you know what if
you didn't observe it very accurately
there's all these questions that are
left completely ambiguous in the
conventional Copenhagen interpretation
of quantum mechanics so what's the
alternative
well whatever it says is that indeed the
cat can be in a superposition of awaken
asleep but you the person opening the
box are also a quantum mechanical system
you are part of the wave function of the
universe and what happens when you open
the box is that not the wave function
collapses but rather that you become
entangled with the cat there is part of
the cat the part of the cat's wave
function that says the cat is awake and
there's part of your function that says
I have seen the cat be awake
there's also part of the cat's wave
function that says the cat is asleep and
there's part of your wave function that
says I have seen the cat asleep and
those different parts of the two
different wave functions are entangled
with each other in the big wave function
of the universe
so there's one branch in which the cat
is awake and you saw it awake and
there's another branch in which the cat
is asleep and you saw it asleep and both
of those branches are absolutely real
and again the existence these two
branches is
simply predicted by the Schrodinger
equation it's not made up it's not added
in in any way it just results from
taking the Schrodinger equation
seriously and taking the fact that you
are a quantum mechanical system and
become can become entangled with the cat
also very seriously so that's fine as
far as it goes but now that we've talked
a little bit about decoherence we can do
a little bit better at that description
the wave function of the universe didn't
really branch when you opened the box it
opened it branched as soon as the cat
became entangled with its own
environment after all in the box there's
all these photons and there's these air
molecules and so forth parts of the
environment we don't keep track of as
soon as the cat became entangled with
that which is right away which is
incredibly fast right then the universe
branched into two different pieces and
you were already on one branch or the
other even before you open the box even
though you didn't know it okay so that
is how an ever reading would describe
Schrodinger's cat why am i pausing to
describe four ringers cat in the middle
of talking about entanglement and the
emergence of space-time because we can
still ask the question why is it that
when we open the box we see either the
cat only awake or asleep I've said it's
because we become entangled with the cat
but why do we become entangled in that
particular way right there's either a
cat awake and I saw the cat awake or a
cat asleep and I saw the cat asleep in
quantum mechanics if I'm just doing the
math I'm just writing down what the
wavefunction could be there are awake
cats there are sleep cats but there's
also any superposition of awake and
asleep right I said before we never see
super positions and so now we can start
confronting the question well why not
why can't we just obey the rules of the
universe open the box and see the cat in
a superposition or for that matter why
can't we believe ourselves to be in a
superposition the wavefunction collapses
would be the traditional Copenhagen
answer the wave function branches is the
Eveready an answer but it branches in a
very particular way
so why is it in other words that on
individual branches of the wavefunction
we either see in a way cat or in a sleep
cat not some combination of both and the
answer is is lies in two things we've
already discussed one is decoherence and
the other is locality so think about
those particles in the Box the photons
the atoms that we said keep bumping into
the cat and therefore dqo hearing its
wavefunction branching the wave function
of the universe well if the cat is
asleep there's a certain way that
certain photons in the box will bump
into it when you take a picture of your
cat what you're actually taking a
picture of is the photons that have
bumped into your cat right and entered
your camera your phone or whatever and
they would bump into the cat in a
different way if the cat was awake and
walking around if you take a picture of
your cat awake you see it somewhere
different than if it's asleep okay
that's not a score strictly true now the
cat metaphor is getting away from us a
little bit because in a way cat can look
very very much like an asleep cat let's
imagine for the purposes of this thought
experiment that the awake cat is up and
meowing and wants to get out of the box
and the sleep cat is in a different
position lying on the floor of the box
peacefully snoring okay so the thing
about the awake cat and the asleep cat
is that they describe different
positions in space and therefore the
photons that bump into them are
different right a photon bumps into a
cat when it arrives at the position of
the cat or at least the position of the
cat's fur or something like that and the
set of photons which bumps into the
awake cat will be different than the set
of photons it bumps into the asleep cat
that is why it's these two versions of
the cat that are observable you will see
in a way cat or you will see in a sleep
cat you will never see a combination of
both if the cat was in a superposition
of awake and asleep as soon as any
photons hit it they would know did I hit
the awake cat or did I hit the sleep cat
or both or neither or whatever and the
universe would branch but on any one
branch when I have a cap that is asleep
all the photons are hitting
the same way there's not further extra
branching over and on top of that so the
reason why according to Everett or at
least according to Eveready in quantum
mechanics the reason why you see the cat
as either awake or asleep is because
those are the two possibilities that are
spatially coherent those are the two
possibilities that describe a system
that has a well-defined configuration in
space and why is space so important here
this I'm talking not about like outer
space I mean like the space in which we
live the three dimensions of space up
down left right forward backward space
is important because interactions such
as the interactions of the photons with
the cat are local in space so there is a
deep deep connection between locality
which is a feature of the laws of
physics and the emergence of the
classical world the emergence of the
fact that when we open boxes we see cats
awake or asleep but not a superposition
of both its locality and the process of
decoherence that together make the world
look approximately classical to us so
that's a crucially important fact right
that's what locality is doing for us
it's helping decoherence proceed in a
particular way to give us a particular
classical world now all of that of
course does what I said we really don't
want to do it starts with classical
notions like locations in space and uses
those to develop this picture we
ultimately wants to go the other way
around okay we don't want to presume the
existence of space and particles or
anything like that because in the
fundamental way that we have of talking
about reality according to Everett what
the world is is a quantum mechanical
wave function the world is not particles
and fields spread throughout space those
are what we see when we observe the
world but the world is much richer than
that the world is this quantum wave
function in this very abstract high
dimensional mathematical space okay we
want to make the journey from this
abstract quantum mechanical wave
function to the world that we see what
we're arguing is that a
crucial role is played by the fact that
interactions are local in space but
that's a cheat a little bit because
we're using the notion of space and
we're supposed to be deriving the notion
of space that's okay the trick is to
just reverse the logic rather than
saying interactions are local in space
what you should say is space is the
property with respect to which
interactions are local okay there's a
little bit of a mind bender right there
but that's gonna be the fundamental
driving idea that lets us talk about how
space emerges from the wavefunction in
other words we have some abstract
quantum mechanical thing we don't even
have the vocabulary for this thing in
ordinary natural language right in the
English language we have a quantum wave
function technically for the
mathematically inclined out there it is
a vector in a gigantic mathematical
space called Hilbert space
when I say gigantic you know how we have
three dimensions of space around us up
down left right forward backward any
vector space has a certain number of
dimensions the number of dimensions of
Hilbert space is at least 10 to the 10
to the 120 - that's a very very big
number okay 1 followed by a number of
zeros and that number of zeroes is 10 to
the 120 - which is 1 followed by 122
zeroes it's a huge number and maybe
Hilbert space is actually infinitely big
we don't know about that but we want to
go from this incredibly abstract mess to
this specific idea of particles moving
in space and what we're saying is that
in the emergent space the thing that
makes space special is that interactions
are local in it so we want to do in
other words to say of all the different
ways there might be in principle to
describe this abstract crazy quantum
state this wavefunction there will be
certain special good ways the good ways
are those that make manifest the idea
that different parts of the wavefunction
interact with each other only when they
are nearby and again I'm reluctantly
even saying those words because we're
going to be defining
nearby to be when the things can
interact with each other okay so let me
let me stop a little bit to give one
little footnote here this is already
abstract and hard to follow enough
I mentioned that Hilbert space the space
of all possible quantum wave functions
is very very high dimensional it might
be infinite it might be 10 to the 10 to
the 120 - or might be some number in
between but I will be assuming
furthermore that it's finite okay this
is a big assumption this finite the
number that is finite is the
dimensionality of Hilbert space the
number of completely independent quantum
wave functions that we can possibly
contemplate it's a huge number but it's
still a finite number that is by no
means settled as a true fact about
reality physicists do not know whether
Hilbert space is finite dimensional or
infinite dimensional we do not know
whether there is only a finite number of
different possible quantum wave
functions that are independent from each
other or whether there's potentially an
infinite number okay the reason why you
might think there's a finite number this
this will take a whole other podcast to
talk about and I did talk about it a
little bit with Lenny Susskind but it
all comes down to the entropy of black
holes
black holes Stephen Hawking pointed out
all the way back in the 1970s have an
entropy an entropy you know is a way of
characterizing the messiness the
disorderliness the randomness of a
system and the black hole entropy like
the entropy of any other quantum
mechanical system in some ways is
telling us the number of different
possible arrangements of that system
that are contributing to the macroscopic
reality of the system all the different
possible arrangements that matter for
this particular thing so there's two
things about black holes that are very
important one is the they are maximum
entropy configurations for any one
region of space if you take a region of
space and try to fit more and more
entropy into it eventually the more
entropy is associated with more energy
and the whole thing will just collapse
to make a black hole and the black hole
will always have equal to or more
entropy than the stuff you made it
out of in fact it always has more as a
matter of fact so if you try to fit more
entropy into a region of space then a
black hole would have all you do is get
a bigger black hole that doesn't fit
into that region anymore so this seems
to be telling us that according to
gravity which is necessary for making
black holes there's only a finite number
of different states that you can ever
have in a region of space which we turn
quantum mechanically into the statement
that there's a finite dimensional
hilbert space there's only a finite
dimensional set of different quantum
states that could possibly describe what
is happening okay so that finite number
of degrees of freedom if you want to
call it that a finite number of things
that could go on in any particular
region of space that is a completely
different conclusion than you would
reach in conventional quantum field
theory you know those of you that have
been listening to me talk for many years
know that quantum field theory is the
way the best way that modern physicists
have of describing the world if you want
to talk about the standard model of
particle physics the Higgs boson quantum
electrodynamics quantum chromodynamics
these are all quantum field theories
they start with the idea there's a field
in space and they quantize that idea
they follow this paradigm of starting
with a classical description fields
moving through space and quantizing it
it is always true when you quantize a
quantum field theory the resulting space
of wave functions is infinite
dimensional there are an infinite number
of things that can go on when you have a
field theory because literally the field
has a different value at every point in
space and there's an infinite number of
points in space it's really just that
simple
so I want you to figure out you know
what is being sent here because it's
kind of big and important on the one
hand our best current way of describing
the world is using quantum field theory
quantum field theory directly implies
that there is a there are an infinite
number of degrees of freedom in any one
region of space there's an infinite
dimensional hilbert space that you need
to describe all the possible quantum
wave functions on the other hand
remember gravity doesn't fit in to
quantum field theory gravity Einstein
general theory of relativity is the one
part of modern physics that doesn't seem
to be able to be described by an
ordinary quantum field theory and
furthermore I mean the reason reasons
why that's true is because they're both
technical problems things blow up and
become infinity and also there's
conceptual problems it typically in
quantum field theory you say things like
I just said right there are there are
fields that have values at every point
in space if you try to quantize gravity
now gravity describes space-time as
having curvature and if you quantize
gravity presumably that means that
there's a superposition of different
geometries that space at time could be
in but if that's true we don't know how
to describe quote-unquote a point in
space what you might finger as a single
point in space around you right now
might be in a different location or
might not even be mapable to a single
location in some different part of the
wave function of the universe this is my
feeble attempt at making understandable
in real language the fact that quantum
gravity makes locality very very hard to
talk about because points in space can't
be singled out in any simple way anyway
the point of all that was to say there
are both technical problems and
conceptual problems with quantizing
gravity that means the quantum gravity
is not well described by a quantum field
theory so when the one hand quantum
field theory says there an infinite
number of states possible in every
region of space gravity seems to say
there are only a finite number of things
that can possibly happen in any region
of space and the number 10 to the 10 to
the 120 two comes from the fact that our
universe only has a certain observable
part of it right our universe is
expanding and the expansion of the
universe is accelerating so if a black
hole has an entropy and therefore a
finite number of things that can happen
inside that's because there's a horizon
around the black hole and the entropy of
the black hole is just the area of that
horizon in Planckian units well guess
what we in the universe are inside of a
horizon because our universes
expanding and accelerating there is a
horizon around us and there's an entropy
of our observable universe that turns
out to be about ten to the hundred and
twenty-two when you go through the
numbers so if this gravity hint is
pointing us on the right track the
observable universe only has a finite
number of things that can possibly be
happening within it a finite number of
degrees of freedom a finite dimensional
hilbert space that's very different from
the quantum field theory story and to be
perfectly honest this presents a fork in
the road for physicists who would like
to quantize gravity one fork in the road
says well the hints from black hole
entropy that that the number of degrees
of freedom is finite in the universe are
just wrong they're misleading
quantum field theory is more successful
than anything we know about gravity we
should follow down the road of quantum
field theory and imagine there are an
infinite number of things that could
happen in any region but there's a whole
other way to go which says no quantum
field theory is only a pretty good
approximation quantum field theory takes
space very seriously
right puts it front and center fields
exist throughout space quantum gravity
can't take space nearly as seriously
because space is going to be in a
superposition of doing many different
things
therefore we should take the hints from
black hole entropy as foundational as
central here and in that case we should
be dealing with finite numbers of
degrees of freedom in quantum gravity
finite dimensional hilbert spaces we
don't know which fork in this which road
to take in this fork in the road
which direction to go in I'm going to
choose to go down the road that says
there's only a finite number of degrees
of freedom in every region of space okay
the quantum field theory is not the
final story that there's something
deeper than quantum field theory and in
some sense simpler right a finite number
of degrees of freedom is simpler than an
infinite number of degrees of freedom so
maybe that's a good thing there are
problems that come up we'll talk about
what some of those problems are how you
map on to the successes in experiments
of quantum field theory if you only have
a fine
number of degrees of freedom to play
with but there we go that is the
assumption I'm going to make so where
does that leave us where are we we
imagine that the universe is described
by a wave function at least the
observable universe is described by a
wave function in a finite dimensional
hilbert space and we want to take
advantage of the idea that locality
determines how the laws of physics work
that is to say space locations in space
are the things with respect to which
interactions between different parts of
the universe look local ok locality that
I think I probably messed that one up
space is the reasoning with respect to
which interactions look local
so that might just seem you know like a
happy motto to put forward but very
difficult to deal with in practice and
it is it's it's hard so the task before
us is to go from this abstract quantum
wave function and find the universe
within it find the universe that we know
and love this is not a task that has
been getting a lot of attention in the
history of physics right like I said
before no matter how good you are at
quantum mechanics the traditional thing
to do has always been to start with a
classical theory and to quantize it this
whole project of starting with a true
quantum mechanical description and
seeing how the classical world emerges
has simply not been the focus of
anyone's research for generations now so
we are finally beginning to take this
question seriously so we're it's baby
steps it's right at the beginning of
something that is very exciting but not
yet fully developed by any stretch so a
little bit of progress was made just a
couple years ago by a group of students
at Stanford University
Kotler and and at all I'm going to
forget all their names sorry about that
so they said the following thing let's
let's imagine you really did have the
most abstract description of a quantum
system you could have so it's not the
quantum system of particles moving in
space or of Springs or of spins or
anything like that it's not the quantum
mechanical description of anything it's
just a quantum theory
all by itself you have wavefunctions and
you have Schrodinger's equation the
Schrodinger equation says here's how the
wave function evolves with time and they
asked the question given only that
information could you reverse engineer
could you go backwards could you figure
out what this was a quantum mechanical
description of could you figure out sort
of the precursor classical looking
theory that had you quantized it would
have given you this quantum mechanical
description and in particular they
focused in on the question of locality
so you have a wavefunction as I said
wave functions are typically even if
they're finite dimensional the number of
dimensions is very very big so you can
divide it up you can choose to consider
this wave function to be the combination
of many many little subsystems
interacting with each other and becoming
entangled and what locality means in
this context is that the different
subsystems will interact with their
neighbors but not interact with other
things in fact if you don't even want to
prejudice it by using the word neighbors
different subsystems will interact with
only a small number of other systems in
the bigger wave function and those other
cysts subsystems will interact with it
just a small number of other subsystems
etc that is the way that locality can
emerge rather than saying this little
piece of the universe only interacts
with its neighbors you say this little
piece of the universe only interacts
with a small number of other pieces of
the universe which we will then call its
neighbors that's what it means to be a
neighbor rather than saying two things
interact when their neighbors two things
are neighbors when they interact and
what caller at all were able to show is
that for a given abstract quantum system
usually there's no way of doing that at
all usually there's no way of taking an
abstract quantum system and dividing it
into a bunch of little local subsystems
just talking to their neighbors but
sometimes there are and when there are
when there is that way is usually unique
in other words there's not multiple ways
of dividing the big one away
functioning too many little local
subsystems there's more or less one way
and there's certain footnotes about what
more or less means in that context but
the point is and this is just really
important and exciting and crucial that
you don't need to start with space and
locality you can start with an abstract
quantum mechanical system ask yourself
the question is there any way of
describing it so that it looks like a
bunch of things interacting locally in
space and the answer is when the answer
is yes there's a unique way more or less
of doing it you can take away function
and chop it up into local local pieces
okay that's how space in the sense of
things are next to each other or far
away etc can emerge from the quantum
mechanical wave function now that's a
good step that's I think like I said is
I think it's crucially important it's
fascinating it's it's going to be the
basis for a lot of work going forward
but it's just a very first tiny step
these folks were not thinking about
gravity they were thinking about space
but they were not thinking about the
much richer set of things that happen in
Einstein's universe Einstein says not
only there's space but space is part of
space-time and that space-time is
dynamical and moves around and it warps
and has geometry and that geometry gives
us the force of gravity as we know it so
we want to go from simply the notion of
locality and interacting in space to the
much richer notion of a dynamical curved
space-time geometry how do we do that
the answer you will not be surprised
again if you've been listening to my
rants over the years is to be found in
the notion of entropy okay no big
surprise entropy is the answer to
everything is you know the short motto
for all of my discussions about just
about everything where does that come
from what does entropy have to do with
anything
I breezed over the idea that black holes
have entropy and that that somehow tells
us how many degrees of freedom there are
in a region but let's be a little bit
more specific okay remember we said that
entanglement between different parts of
the universe different subsystems of the
universe is at the heart of quantum
mechanics
so let's you know forget about our
ambitions for the moment
about emergent space-time and so forth
let's go back to our quantum field
theory way of thinking about things or
even better let's let's you know what we
call regularize our quantum field theory
which is to say let's take apart the
infinite number of things going on and
imagine a lattice imagine literally some
network of little quantum mechanical
degrees of freedom maybe electrons or
something that are interacting with each
other in some lattice structure okay and
you let it settle down so you imagine
that this system is in what we call its
vacuum state its lowest energy State
there's an amazing thing that is true
you can take some subsystem right some
region of space so there's some degrees
of freedom inside and there's some
outside they're going to be entangled
with each other this is a generic
feature of quantum field theory that
degrees of freedom in any one location
in space are entangled in the vacuum
state with degrees of freedom all over
the place everywhere else in the
universe they're highly entangled with
other nearby degrees of freedom and they
are only a little tiny bit entangled
with degrees of freedom far away but
everything is a little bit entangled
with everything else and you can go
through the math okay you can say I have
a region of space so there's an inside
and outside and there's a boundary
between this region the region has a
volume and the boundary has an area okay
that's how things work if space has
three dimensions remember we're assuming
space for the moment just to get some
lessons to build on later down the line
it turns out that the entanglement
between what's inside the region inside
the boundary and outside the boundary
gives rise to entropy the entanglement
entropy of a system was described by
john von neumann early on in the days of
quantum mechanics it's basically because
you know if you think of entropy as
saying there's something I don't know
right something that the system I'm
describing is in a superposition or a
combination of many different
possibilities even if you know the
entire wave function of the universe if
you only keep track of what's going on
on one side of a boundary the inside or
the outside then for all intents and
purposes you don't know what's going on
on the
other side and you can describe you can
it's a sign that lack of perfect
knowledge and entropy so unlike
classical systems where entropy really
comes from some ignorant there's
something you don't know in quantum
mechanics there's a new kind of entropy
an entropy that just arises from
entanglement
that's the funnyman entropy or the
entanglement entropy okay and
furthermore you can calculate what it
looks like and in the system that we're
describing where there's a region of
space with an inside and an outside it
turns out that that entropy of the
region inside is proportional to the
area of the boundary which makes perfect
sense right because if there are degrees
of freedom that are deep in the interior
of the region they're mostly unentangled
I should say they are entangled but only
a little bit with degrees of freedom
very far away most of the entanglement
is between nearby degrees of freedom
which means most of the entanglement is
happening just across the boundary and
therefore the bigger the area of the
boundary the more entanglement there's
gonna be and the more entropy there's
going to be so this is a very general
feature there's nothing to the gravity
yet okay this is just a feature of
quantum field theories or theories on
lattices that you could then take the
limit as the lattice gets very very
close together to make a quantum field
theory regions of space have an entropy
that entropy is proportional to the area
at least when the system as a whole is
in its vacuum state in its lowest energy
state that's a crucial footnote actually
because I could invent different states
in which the entropy was much higher
because I said different parts of the
system are entangled with each other
with their nearest neighbors mostly and
only a little bit with things further
away I could invent a different state
where things inside my region are highly
entangled with things far away so if I
didn't have gravity if I just had a
fixed space-time and I took a region of
it the maximum entropy I could put in
that region is not proportional to the
area of the boundary it's proportional
to the volume of the region because
that's how many degrees of freedom are
in
sort of one for every little part in
space one for every cubic plank length
or whatever it is okay so without
gravity the maximum entropy in a region
goes like the volume of the region but
the actual entropy when the whole system
is in its vacuum state goes as the area
now in 1995 Ted Jacobsen who is an
ingenious theoretical physicist at the
University of Maryland made a bold
suggestion he said well what if you do
that kind of discussion take a region of
space calculate its entropy but you turn
on gravity you say that gravity is
important and of course we know how
gravity works Einstein gave us an
equation okay Einstein's equation tells
us how space-time responds to matter and
energy
what Jacobson suggested and you know
this is how theoretical physics works
you make up an idea you make a
suggestion see where it goes he said
maybe there's something special about
gravity which makes it work like the
following thing in a in the
non-gravitational context the entropy of
the vacuum state is proportional to the
area but in principle it could be much
higher what if in gravity the entropy of
a region is always proportional to the
area of its boundary in other words I
could imagine trying to increase the
entropy of a region by increasing the
entanglement of things inside with
things outside but Jacobson suggests
what that amounts to is also increasing
the amount of energy inside the region
and we know from general relativity that
if you have energy in a region the
geometry of space is going to change and
that includes the area of the boundary
so Jacobson says oh look maybe in
general relativity or at least in a
theory with gravity there is a feature
there's a new law of nature that says
that the area of every region is
proportional to the entropy of the
region inside so even if you try to
excite or change a system in a certain
region of space space-time has a
geometry that adjusts to make sure that
the area of the surrounding boundary
is always proportional to the entropy
inside okay I mean that's a suggestion
right you can imagine something like
that but what Jacobson showed is that if
you take that suggestion at face value
you can derive an equation relating the
entropy to the geometry and then you
could derive another equation relating
the entropy to the energy and by doing
that you get an equation relating the
geometry to the energy which is exactly
what you have in general relativity and
in fact Jacobson argued it is exactly
Einstein's equation for general
relativity so Einstein in some sense
simply assumed his equation he proposed
it he said what if the geometry of
space-time is related to energy and
matter in a certain way what Jacobson
says is what if the geometry of
space-time is related to entropy in a
certain way and he claims that he can
then derive einstein's equation from
that new assumption this is a program
called thermodynamic gravity or entropic
gravity Eric Berlin died and others have
worked on later versions of entropic
gravity basically imagining that even if
we don't know what's going on in quantum
gravity there are some degrees of
freedom in the universe that interact
with each other in some particular ways
and from the properties of entanglement
and entropy of those degrees of freedom
we can derive the geometry of space-time
and the natural thing for that geometry
to do is to obey Einstein's equation
this is just a wonderful idea you know
very creative and very novel and has
very far-reaching potential consequences
even those 1995 so it's over 20 years
now pushing 25 years my goodness it's
still something that physicists have not
quite yet come to terms with we're
thinking about it you know we're trying
to get our brains around it this basic
idea that from entropy and area we can
derive all of gravity okay now Jacobsen
of course wasn't doing quantum gravity
you might think he was because we're
talking about quantum mechanics and
we're talking about gravity but he
assumed that there was a space-time
there
basically a classical space-time and
that space-time was responding to
quantum mechanical matter living within
it so this is what is called semi
classical quantum gravity it's not true
quantum gravity and true quantum gravity
space-time itself should be quantum but
in Jacobson's Theory space-time was
classical and matter was quantum so what
we would like to do the ambition now is
to derive space-time itself from
something purely quantum mechanical and
we now know from Kotler at all that we
could imagine that the idea of space
itself could emerge from the quantum
mechanical wave function so what if we
basically took these two sets of ideas
locality and position emerging from the
wave function and the geometry of
space-time being driven by the entropy
of different degrees of freedom and
combined them this is essentially what
was done in a couple of papers that I've
written with Charles tau and Spiros
Michael aqus Charles and Spiros and I
wrote one paper and then Charles and I
followed up spiros his name you might
know like me he is served
not only is he a mathematical physicist
but he's also served as a consultant on
movies he was in particular consultant
on ant-man and it's spiros his fault
there's something called the quantum
realm that plays such an important role
in the Marvel Universe because he got a
man to start talking about the quantum
realm and was all over once that
happened okay but when he's not palying
around with Hollywood celebrities he's a
physicist and Charles was a graduate
student who is now a postdoc at the
University of Maryland and we put
together this idea of space-time
emerging from Hilbert space
okay so space in fact we didn't really
talk about time that much to be
perfectly honest but the geometry of
space emerging from an abstract quantum
mechanical description so basically what
we said is again if you think about how
things work in the simple cases where we
understand what's going on
in the vacuum state of a quantum field
theory you have this idea the two
degrees of freedom that are nearby will
be highly entangled two degrees of
freedom
that are far away will be less entangled
collar it all show that you can use that
kind of thing and turn it around you can
define what you mean to be a nearest
neighbor by having a lot of interaction
with Charles and Spiros and I suggest it
is you can extend that what you can say
is you can define the distance between
two parts of the universe between two
parts of the wave function of the
universe to be inversely proportional to
the amount of entanglement so if two
degrees of freedom are highly entangled
they are nearby if they are not very
entangled they are further away in the
follow of paper that Charles and I wrote
we did this much more respectably in a
much more respectable mathematical way
really looking at areas that you can
define in this emergent space-time and
connecting them to n trapeze basically a
you know there's math here you can read
our papers I encourage you to do that
but the point is we asked if you let not
just a notion of locality emerge from
the quantum wave function but a
full-blown geometry of space let that
emerge from the wave function there's a
natural way to define it and then you
can follow Jacobson's logic and you can
say what are the equations that should
be obeyed by this geometry and guess
what you find
Einstein's equation you find the same
equation relating to geometry to matter
that Albert Einstein proposed back in
1915 now I need to immediately jump in
here and and point out that I don't over
claim because it sounds amazing and it
is amazing but it's amazing with a lot
of footnotes ok we made a lot of
assumptions and the biggest assumption
was we only work in the weak field limit
of distortions of the geometry of space
so a mild not very noticeable
gravitational field not like a black
hole or the Big Bang or something like
that
ok so we showed that under certain very
explicitly delineated assumptions in the
situation where gravity was weak the
relationship between entropy and area
that defines geometry naturally led to
Hine Stein's equation in a purely
emergent space-time so unlike Jacobson
who started with space
and then got Einstein's equation we
start with a quantum wave function and
we say that the natural geometry to be
defined on the space that naturally
emerges from the quantum wave function
naturally obeys the equations of gravity
as we know and love them let me pause
for a moment to talk about policy genius
and the idea of buying life insurance I
know a lot of people probably a lot of
younger listeners don't even think about
life insurance but it's something that
brings you a little bit of peace of mind
and any complications that might exist
about what policy should I buy from whom
should I buy it that's exactly where
policy genius can be very helpful it
lets you get a quote
comparing many different actual insurers
all at the same time so you can shop for
the best price and then once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and red tape
this goes for life insurance in
particular because September is national
life insurance awareness month the
policy genius will do this for any kind
of insurance for home insurance auto
disability insurance what-have-you
so if you need life insurance but you
haven't gotten around to it national
life insurance awareness month is as
good a time as any to get started go to
policy genius.com
get the quotes you can apply in minutes
you can do the whole thing on your phone
right now like I said it brings you a
little peace of mind
do it forget it move on with living your
life this is I think it's as exciting as
it sounds I think it's very very
interesting because nowhere there
nowhere in that description that I use
words like string theory or loop quantum
gravity or causal sets or any of those
things all of those ideas which may very
well be important and relevant to the
final answer but all of them start from
some classical description of the world
and then quantize them okay that is what
everyone has done at every other attempt
to quantize gravity in the history of
quantizing gravity we are really doing
something different by trying to start
with the abstract wavefunction and
rather than quantizing gravity we are
finding gravity within quantum mechanics
even if our current understanding of how
to do that is very primitive and limited
I think that the prospect for doing that
is extremely
now one of the reasons why it's limited
is because in fact it's not just we
haven't done it yet but the thing that
we've done cannot possibly be the entire
story and I think that you know our our
papers have been noticed and people have
cited them but they've not lit the world
on fire and I think I know why I dunno
why because there's a couple reasons why
but a big one is one of the things we do
think that we've learned about quantum
gravity over the past 20 years is that
locality is not fundamental everything
that I said over the past whatever it is
20 minutes about finding the emergent
space-time geometry within the wave
function of the universe is based on
this idea of locality based on this idea
that you can define a position in space
using the fact that degrees of freedom
can only interact when they're at the
same position or at least right next to
each other in the space and that seems
to be an absolutely crucial part of
quantum field theory but not of quantum
gravity so in the weak field limit
Einstein's theory of general relativity
looks very much like an ordinary
classical field theory but when things
become strong such as when you have a
black hole the locality that we know and
love from field theory seems to break
down seems to be somehow avoided in
certain very very subtle ways and this
is not something we understand very well
and it might even go away but I think
it's right I think it's on the right
track so the basic idea involves words
like holography and complementarity so
let me just give you the very very
briefest introduction to what those
words mean in this context we said that
a black hole has an entropy and the
entropy is proportional to its area okay
so back when people first started
thinking about this they were surprised
by that if instead of a black hole if
you have a box of gas a box of gas has
an entropy that is proportional to the
volume of the box of gas if you increase
the volume while keeping the density of
gas inside the same the entropy goes up
with the volume going up so they were
confused as to why the entropy of a
black hole went
it's area now with the story I've just
told you with entanglement and degrees
of freedom and nearby locality etc it is
less surprising to you that the entropy
of a black hole goes as the area of its
event horizon but they were surprised
back then okay so we thought a lot about
how to make sense of this idea that
somehow a black hole is a maximum
entropy state and yet it's entropy only
went as its area not as its volume okay
and it was suggested by Leni Susskind
among others Gerardi tuft was one of the
other ones that there was something
holographic going on in the following
sense that you think that the interior
of a black hole is three-dimensional
let's forget about extra dimensions of
space or anything like that a black hole
is a two-dimensional event horizon
around a three-dimensional interior and
so the theory the sort of physical
description of what's happening inside
the black hole you might think describes
different objects different things that
fall into the black hole bumping into
each other in this three-dimensional
space but the holographic principle says
there's another way of thinking about
the black hole which is sort of puts
everything on the boundary imagines that
what is really happening inside the
black hole can be entirely 100%
described simply by giving information
that is located at the two dimensional
boundary of the black hole in other
words rather than thinking of the black
hole as a set of degrees of freedom
scattered throughout the
three-dimensional volume inside if you
think about the black hole as a set of
degrees of freedom scattered across the
two-dimensional horizon the boundary
between the inside and the outside
that's the idea of holography and maybe
the idea goes this extends far beyond
black holes maybe all of reality that we
think of as three-dimensional is somehow
encoded in some two-dimensional thing we
don't know where that thing would be or
what kind of surface it would be but it
would be like a hologram right a
two-dimensional hologram when you shine
light on
gives you a three-dimensional looking
image maybe the holographic principle
suggests the whole 3-dimensional world
around us is just a reflection of or an
emergent phenomenon from some underlying
two-dimensional description there's
still a lot we don't know about
holography there is one context in which
it's extremely well understood which is
the anti-de sitter space conformal field
theory correspondents the ad SC ft
correspondence I don't really want to go
into the details about that right now I
did talk a lot about it with Susskind on
our mindscape conversation but basically
it's a model for quantum gravity where
you have an N dimensional boundary where
there's a theory without gravity and
there's an interior with an N plus 1
dimensional space-time so it's a duality
a relationship between an N dimensional
space-time without gravity and an N plus
1 dimensional space-time with gravity
that's holography in action there's just
no question this is a very vivid
calculable you know useful laboratory
for exploring the ideas of holography
the problem is and rather than extolling
the virtues of the ADEs CFT
correspondence i'm gonna go right into
the problem with it it is not the real
world
this space-time that has gravity in it
in the 80s CFD context is a space-time
with a negative vacuum energy a negative
cosmological constant that's why it is
called anti de sitter space de sitter
who is a collaborator of Einstein was
the one who first really sat down and
thought about the cosmological
ramifications of a positive vacuum
energy a positive cosmological constant
and he found a solution to the equations
that were given by Einstein which we now
called de sitter space if you have a
negative cosmological constant you get
anti-de sitter space and people figure
that out
the problem is anti de sitter space uses
a negative cosmological constant that's
the context in which we best understand
holography but the real world seems to
have a positive cosmological constant we
discovered in 1998 that the universe is
accelerating expanding faster and faster
that corresponds to a positive value of
the bank
so even though anti-de sitter space is
crucially important as a worked example
of holography in action it's not the
real world and I do get you know I do
feel like maybe I say this very
hesitatingly but I do feel like maybe
we're spending too much time as a field
investigating and exploring the
implications of anti-de sitter space
it's because you know the old joke I say
this in the book it's the old joke about
looking for your keys under a lamppost
right you meet a drunk guy he's lost his
keys she's looking for the keys and at
some point you're helping him and you
don't see the keys anywhere and you say
are you sure you lost your keys here and
the drunk guy says oh no I lost them
over there but the light is much better
here under the lamppost
so anti-de sitter space is a really
bright lamppost when it comes to
holography and quantum gravity but it's
not where we lost our keys it's not the
world we live in so what I'm doing what
Charles and Spiros and I and other
people are doing is trying something
that is harder than anti-de sitter space
in some sense it's less well defined but
at least it's the real world we are not
taking advantage of the negative
cosmological constant the ad SCT relies
on so heavily anyway that was one thing
holography the other thing is so sorry
to complete the thought a DSC FD is
evidence that locality can't be purely
fundamental you have two different
descriptions of the world with different
numbers of dimensions of space I mean
how different could that be something
that is local in one description on the
boundary let's say is wildly non-local
in the other description and vice-versa
but they're both equally good so one
person's locality is another person's
non locality this is a reflection of the
fact that locality can't be quite as
central and fundamental in quantum
gravity as it was in quantum field
theory complementarity is an idea that
takes that one step further
complementarity arises from the idea
that we want to allow black holes to
evaporate to give off Hawking radiation
and disappear without destroying the
quantum information that falls into them
this is
black hole information loss problem
another thing that I don't want to get
into right now it's in the book I talked
about it with Susskind and I think a
little bit with Penrose but it's hard to
get the information out of black holes
you throw a book into a black hole it
falls into the singularity if you don't
want to allow that information to be
destroyed somehow the information in the
book needs to escape in the outgoing
radiation and there are very good
arguments that simply cannot happen if
locality is a hundred percent respected
if the book has a location in space you
can follow it it's gonna hit the
singularity it's information is not
going to escape into the radiation so
Susskind again and collaborators
suggested this idea of horizon or black
hole complementarity complementarity was
used in this context first by Niels Bohr
back in the pioneering days of quantum
mechanics and complementarity refers to
the idea there's two different ways of
looking at something and neither one of
them is right or wrong they're both true
but they can't both be true at the same
time so what Bohr would say is something
can have a position or it could have a
velocity but it can't have both at the
same time something could be a particle
or it could be a wave but they can't be
both at the same time what Susskind
wants to say is that what's going on in
the black hole could be described by
ordinary local quantum field theory
inside the black hole or it can be
described by a set of degrees of freedom
scattered across the boundary the event
horizon of the black hole but not both
at the same time in particular if you
fall into the black hole you don't
notice anything when you fought when you
fall across the event horizon everything
looks normal and ordinary and
three-dimensional to you but according
to complementarity from the point of
view of an outside observer that's not
what they see in fact they never even
see you cross the event horizon they see
you just get red shifted and move more
and more slowly and with Susskind says
is what they see is your quantum
information becomes spread around the
event horizon you
get sort of smeared on to this
two-dimensional surface so things look
like local three-dimensional quantum
field theory to the infalling observer
but it looks like a two-dimensional
membrane just outside the black hole
from the point of view of someone
outside the black hole that is what is
called horizon complementarity now again
even compared to a DSC Ft we have much
less understanding of how to make this
evocative idea into something specific
and rigorous and quantitative people
have done work on it made progress
etcetera but it's still a little hand
waving a little vague but the lesson
seems to be clear if you by any of these
arguments at all and again not everyone
does I I do like I tend to believe
they're on the right track if you
believe these lessons from black hole
physics what they seem to be teaching us
is that the idea of describing reality
as a set of degrees of freedom with
definite locations in space is not the
final answer it's not the fundamental
once and for all way of thinking about
the emergence of the universe from a
quantum mechanical wave function so this
is big news if it's true right this says
that where you are in space is not a
fundamental thing in the best theory
that we have of reality ok that's a
little bit hard to wrap our minds around
and this is why we're still struggling
with it but that seems to be the
implication the stuff that Charles and
Spiros and I and others have done to
think about the emergence of space-time
and the emergence of gravity all assumes
that you can describe the emergence pace
time using locality using locations in
space as a fundamental building block
but it only works in the weak field
limit of gravity when gravity is not
that strong a black hole is exactly
where gravity is very strong so there's
no inconsistency with what we've done
and what we want to do what we want to
do is extend our philosophy of starting
purely with quantum mechanics and
deriving the emergence of a
semi-classical space-time from nothing
else nothing other than the entanglement
properties in the intrinsic quantum
properties of the system
and we want to be able to do that not
only when gravity is weak but also when
gravity is strong there's no barrier to
doing this in principle this is one of
the wonderful things about quantum
mechanics the different ways of
observing a quantum system can get you
different looking answers right so the
idea that a system might look
three-dimensional if you look at it in
one way and look two-dimensional if you
look at it in another way this is very
natural from a quantum mechanical point
of view it takes the idea that we
observe something very seriously and
puts it front and center this is a
perfect system to think about in terms
of Eveready in quantum mechanics and the
emergence of space-time from something
more fundamental there might be more
than one way to chop up space-time to
make it look local depending on how
you're doing your observations so that's
the frontier that's what we're working
on right now to try to take this idea of
emergent space-time from entanglement
the geometry of space as something that
is defined ex post facto from how
different degrees of freedom are
interacting with each other and extend
it away from weak fields to the whole
universe
to include the Big Bang black holes etc
there's a large number of challenges
here right this is not built on firm
ground this is built on a chain of
speculations and guesses and it could
blow up at any time that's life in the
fast lane theoretical physics wise but
we'll see where it goes let me just
mention the most obvious failure mode
for this whole picture which comes back
to this idea that there are only a
finite number of quantum mechanical
degrees of freedom in any one region of
space in every region of space for that
matter again I said that that idea that
there's only a finite number of degrees
of freedom is in conflict with what we
would expect from quantum field theory
in quantum field theory there's always
an infinite number of degrees of freedom
in every region of space and quantum
field theory wasn't just a guess quantum
field theory is in some sense the
natural maybe even arguably the unique
way to reconcile quantum mechanics with
special relativity right special
relativity came ten years B
for general relativity special
relativity says that there's space-time
but it's all just one thing okay and he
doesn't in special relativity Einstein
does not let space-time be curved
there's space-time but it's flat special
relativity is the theory where you say
you can't go faster than the speed of
light and also it says that there's no
such thing as an absolute velocity
through space right there's a relative
velocity of two different objects but
there's no such thing as your absolute
frame of reference everyone's frame of
reference is equally good and if that's
true if those basic features are true
you can kind of see why you need an
infinite number of degrees of freedom
it's a little bit of a leap but but you
can get there because imagine that you
say well I imagine a quantum mechanical
theory where there's a fundamental
distance scale right there's a shortest
distance past which nothing can exist
there's a there's a minimum distance
between any two points in space well
according to special relativity the
actual size of that minimal distance
will look different to different
observers moving at different speeds
with respect to each other right
Lorentz invariance is this idea that
distances change and times change as you
move at different velocities and they
exactly cancel out so that the speed of
light is the same to everyone and so if
one person's long distance is another
person's short distance the only way to
make that a hundred percent completely
compatible as if distances can be
infinitely short because speeds can be
infinitely close to the speed of light
without quite getting there so there
seems to be an incompatibility between
the basic fundamental ideas of special
relativity and the simple idea that
there are only a finite number of
degrees of freedom in any one region of
space that was the hand wavy way of
saying something much more specific and
rigorous and mathematical but it's the
same ultimate upshot which is that if
you have a finite number of degrees of
freedom it's very hard for special
relativity to be exactly true and
special relativity is very important to
us right
it's very foundational for everything
that we do in physics so you might think
well this is just
a killer this says that your ideas are
on the wrong track however there's an
optimistic spin you can put on this you
can say well like anything else no
matter how charmed we might be by a
certain idea in physics the amount that
we accept that idea should only be
proportional to the evidence we have for
it and that should never be a hundred
percent maybe special relativity is just
a really good approximation but not
exactly true
maybe Lorentz invariance is
approximately a feature of nature but
not a precise 100 percent feature of
nature what that implies is the
possibility of future experimental tests
because Lorentz invariance is something
it has been very precisely tested in
experiments both in laboratories and
using Astrophysical data so it's
absolutely possible if we're gonna take
this lemon and make some lemonade out of
it to say that you know maybe a feature
of this particular approach to quantum
gravity is that Lorentz invariance is
not exact and that will be observed in
some future experimental tests there's a
huge problem with quantum gravity in
that gravity itself is extremely
extremely weak and therefore it is very
difficult or maybe impossible to imagine
a an experiment that we could
conceivably do in the near term which
would manifest both quantum mechanical
properties and gravitational properties
at the same time it's very difficult to
get direct experimental constraints on
quantum gravity but maybe we can get
indirect constraints if you say a
feature of gravity is that it means
there's only a finite number of degrees
of freedom and a feature of finite
numbers of degrees of freedom is that
Lorentz invariance is only approximate
then that opens up an experimental
window and maybe experimental quantum
gravity will be one of the frontiers in
the future furthermore there are
implications of this not just
experimentally but conceptually for hard
questions like where did the universe
come from right what did happen at the
Big Bang
we don't know there are different people
including myself who have different
ideas but let me just put out one idea
that follows from this emergent
space-time picked
there's always been a problem a puzzle
sort of mild discomfort and the way that
we think about cosmology if you think
about it in terms of quantum field
theory in quantum field theory right you
have fields filling all of space and
these fields vibrate and you imagine
that there are modes of the field which
is just a fancy way of saying vibrations
of a certain wavelength and as the
universe expands those modes expand
along with it so like a photon in the
Cosmic Microwave Background gets
stretched by the expansion of space it
goes from a short wavelength to a long
wavelength in the rest frame of the
universe but that's weird because you
need to imagine there are an infinite
number of such modes and each of them
starts infinitesimally tiny and then
gets stretched to macroscopic sizes as
the universe expands so everything that
you see around you right now if you took
though its wavelength and shrunk it down
to when the universe began it would be
shorter than the Planck length this
hypothetical length at which quantum
gravity becomes very very important so
it sounds as if somehow new degrees of
freedom are coming into existence as the
universe expands it stretches degrees of
freedom from below the Planck length to
above the Planck length that just sounds
weird it's not in direct conflict with
anything but it kind of makes us
uncomfortable
okay this picture of a finite
dimensional number of degrees of freedom
changes that and gives us a new way of
thinking about it the new way says look
what spacetime is is a number of
entangled degrees of freedom entangled
in such a way as to define this emergent
semi-classical space-time geometry so
maybe what we mean by the expansion of
the universe is not new degrees of
freedom coming into existence
maybe the degrees of freedom were always
there some finite number of degrees of
freedom but what happens is that they
were initially unentangled with the
universe if you have a degree of freedom
that is unentangled with everything else
then for all intents and purposes it's
not part of space-time and in this
picture as space expands what that means
is that degrees of freedom that were
originally unentangled with everything
become entangled join the space-time
continuum and become part of the
geometry of space-time all around us in
fact I wrote a fun little paper with
some collaborators called quantum
circuit cosmology you might know that
now that we do quantum computers there's
a whole burgeoning industry and quantum
circuits just like regular computers
have you know circuit diagrams you write
down an algorithm in terms of and gates
and not gates and so forth you can do
all that with quantum computers and it's
a very natural way of thinking about the
evolution of a quantum system if that
quantum system is number one finite
dimensional and number two has some
notion of locality built into it so that
one part of the system doesn't interact
with everything else just interacts with
some nearest neighbors we are saying
that the universe is exactly like that
and therefore you can think of the whole
universe as a quantum circuit and the
evolution of the universe through time
as the action of all sorts of
generalized versions of and gates and
not gates and so forth is that a useful
way of looking at the universe I really
don't know we'll have to find out this
is again very very early days but I
think it's an exciting prospect to truly
change the way that we think about
cosmology at a fundamental level so the
lesson of all of this you know the one
hand we have some specific suggestions
for how quantum gravity works and how
space-time emerges from the wavefunction
but also I think there's an even deeper
lesson which is the need to take the
foundations of quantum mechanics
seriously when you think about hard
questions in ordinary physics you know
as as we talked about with Adam Becker
it's a remarkable feature of 20th
century physics that quantum mechanics
was at the center of it and yet ever
since roughly 1935 physicists had this
agreement
mostly unwritten agreement but sometimes
written down explicitly to not pay
attention to the measurement problem and
the questions of the foundations of
quantum mechanics I really do think that
this choice that's been made by the
physics community as a whole has hell
thus back enormous Lee when we're
looking at questions that are as hard as
fundamental as quantum gravity and the
inversions of space-time in fact it's
interesting to think that Hugh Everett
when he invented the many-worlds
interpretation was inspired by the
problem of quantum gravity this is back
in the 1950s they already knew general
relativity they could try to quantize
gravity and there are technical problems
that immediately arose but there's also
these conceptual problems and one of
them was if you only had at your
disposal the Copenhagen interpretation
of quantum mechanics then a important
crucial part of quantum mechanics is
that there is an observer the observer
measures the system and the wavefunction
collapses and that's a crucial part of
quantum mechanics and ever said well
what if my system is the whole universe
right then there's no observer observing
it it's just evolving all by itself and
that's what led him to say if we just
have wave functions evolving all by
themselves we don't have collapses or
anything like that what do you get and
the answer was many worlds so the
beginning of many worlds as a
formulation of quantum mechanics was
inspired by quantum gravity maybe
quantum gravity will help maybe I should
say maybe many worlds will repay the
favor maybe thinking about quantum
mechanics from the many-worlds
perspective will help us solve quantum
gravity after all if we know that it's
very difficult to find the right theory
of quantum gravity and we agree that
it's been very difficult to find the
right theory of quantum mechanics maybe
we shouldn't be surprised
maybe we shouldn't expect to get the
right theory of quantum gravity until we
fully understand quantum mechanics I for
one am ambitious optimistic willing to
think that we are actually going to do
this if only because finally we're
taking these foundational questions very
very seriously let's see where it goes
so thanks for listening and now please
enjoy this short snippet from the
audiobook recording of something deeply
hidden which you can get wherever audio
books are sold
chapter 7 order and randomness we're
probability comes from one sunny day in
Cambridge England Elizabeth Anscombe ran
into her teacher Lou
Wittgenstein why do people say that
consign opened in his inimitable fashion
that it was natural to think that the
Sun went around the earth rather than
that the earth turned on its axis hands
comb gave the obvious answer that it
just looks like the Sun goes around the
earth well that can shine replied what
would it have looked like if the earth
had turned on its axis this anecdote
recounted by Anscombe herself and which
Tom Stoppard retold in his play jumpers
is a favorite among Everette Ian's
physicist Sidney Coleman used to relate
it in lectures and philosopher of
physics David Wallace used it to open
his book the emergent multiverse it even
bears a family resemblance to Hugh
Everett's remark - Bryce DeWitt it's
easy to see why the observation is so
relevant any reasonable person when
first told about the many-worlds picture
has an immediate visceral objection it
just doesn't feel like I personally
split into multiple people whenever a
quantum measurement is performed and it
certainly doesn't look like there are
all sorts of other universes existing
parallel to the one I find myself in
well the ever ready and replies
channeling Vic and Stein what would it
feel and look like if many worlds were
true the hope is that people living in
an ever readying universe would
experience just what people actually do
experience a physical world that seems
to obey the rules of textbook quantum
mechanics to a high degree of accuracy
and in many situations is well
approximated by classical mechanics but
the conceptual distance between a
smoothly evolving wavefunction and the
experimental data it is meant to explain
is quite large it's not obvious that the
answer we can give to Vic consigns
question is the one we want
Everett's theory might be austere in its
formulation but there's still a good
amount of work to be done to fully flesh
out its implications in this chapter
we'll confront a major puzzle for many
worlds the origin and nature of
probability the Schrodinger equation is
perfectly deterministic why do
probabilities enter at all and why do
they obey the born rule
probabilities equal amplitudes the
complex numbers the wavefunction
associates with each possible outcome
squared does it even make sense to speak
of the probability of ending up on some
particular branch if there will be a
future version of myself on every branch
in the textbook or Copenhagen versions
of quantum mechanics there's no need to
derive the born rule for probabilities
we just plop it down there as one of the
postulates of the theory why couldn't we
do the same thing in many worlds the
answer is that even though the rule
would sound the same in both cases
probabilities are given by the wave
function squared their meanings are very
different the textbook version of the
born rule really is a statement about
how often things happen or how often
they will happen in the future many
worlds has no room for such an extra
postulate we know exactly what will
happen just from the basic rule that the
wavefunction always obeys the
Schrodinger equation probability in many
worlds is necessarily a statement about
what we should believe and how we should
act not about how often things happen
and what we should believe isn't
something that really has a place in the
postulates of a physical theory it
should be implied by them
moreover as we will see there's neither
any room for an extra postulate nor any
need for one given the basic structure
of quantum mechanics the born rule is
natural and automatic since we tend to
see born rule like behavior in nature
this should give us confidence that
we're on the right track
a framework in which an important result
can be derived from more fundamental
postulates should all else being equal
be preferred to one where it needs to be
separately assumed if we successfully
address this question we will have made
significant headway toward showing the
world we would expect to see if many
worlds were true is the world we
actually do see that is a world that is
closely approximated by classical
physics except for quantum measurement
events during which the probable
of obtaining any particular outcome is
given by the born rule I hope you
enjoyed that tiny excerpt from the audio
book version of something deeply hidden
something deeply hidden should be
available all over the place tomorrow as
I released his podcast on Monday
September 9th
so by September 10th 2019 you can get it
in print in audio or whatever other
format you like I just wanted to thank
everyone who's been supporting the book
everyone who supported my other books
and of course everyone who's been
listening to this podcast and supporting
it in various different ways I really do
appreciate it
here's to many more years of exploring
the secrets of the universe
[Music]
you
[Music]